[Musique]
ce film m'a réellement des prix mais je
pense que ceux qui l'ont vue vont
comprendre pourquoi je vais devoir spoy
le film pour mieux expliquer mes propos
donc désolé d'avancé pour ceux qui ne
l'auraient pas vu
nous nous retrouvons très longtemps
après les films x men où les derniers
milles temps sont wolverine de charles
et caliban cependant charles à plus de
90 ans et wolverine vieilli et tombe
même malade
bref dans ce film le réalisme est poussé
au plus totale et ça fait réellement du
bien contrairement aux autres x-men
charles et wolverine sont de réels
dangers publics
surtout charles qui est devenu très
vieux et qui possède même une maladie du
cerveau
alors quand il fait une crise les
ravages sont donc énormes évidemment et
c'est ce que j'ai vraiment aimé dans ce
film c'est le côté réaliste car les
mutants sont des dangers pour la
population qu'il le veuille ou non la
preuve avec charles alors que dans les
autres films x men c'est tout de même
assez rose les humains normaux ne sont
jamais réellement touché il n'ya pas
réellement de mort ou de grave accident
à part pour tout ce qui est bâtiment
bien sûr mais ça c'est pour le spectacle
que je veux vous dire par là c'est qu'en
fait dans le film pour la première fois
nous avons la présence des comics d'x
men les vrais ou ce sont des super héros
qu'ils ont fait des trucs de ouf et j'en
passe cependant tout le long du film
logan va réfuté ces comics disant que
c'est du bidon que la plupart de ce qui
est dedans et fo est hyper bollée ce
film à cause ou grâce de cette
insistance envers les fausses infos des
comics réfute donc tous les anciens
films x-men que ce serait simplement des
adaptations des comics
ce qui n'est pas vraiment faux mais que
tout est exagéré le film de logan nous
le montre bien
en nous montrant la vie fade de logan et
non le pseudo super héros de wolverine
on pourrait même aller plus loin en
disant que logan est le seul film est
retourné dans le monde réel mais on ne
va peut-être pas aller jusque là
bref pour vous dire que la violence et
la tristesse du film n'est pas là pour
rien elle est là pour nous montrer la
réalité
qu'est-ce qui se passerait avec des
mutants dans la vie de tous les jours
soit des réels dangers pour la
population et ville donc à l'écart
ce ne sont pas des superhéros malgré
leur vieillesse ils doivent vivre à
l'écart du monde et travailler pour
gagner un peu d'argent
les super héros ça n'existe pas peu
importe le pouvoir tous les anciens
films x men serait alors bidon et donc
serait que des adaptations des comics ou
bien seulement extrapolés pour plaire
aux enfants à leur faire croire aux
super héros mais il n'en est rien et au
final ce qui me faire réellement pensé
tout ça est la fin du film
logan tombe finalement malades ses
pouvoirs sont très diminué il vieillit
et au final moeurs voilà la réalité et
même si ça me fait chier que wolverine
soit mort il faut l'accepter
alors que dans les comics il est dit que
wolverine prend la place de charles et
enseignes nouveaux mutants les enfants
sauvés dans le film pour ceux qui
n'auraient pas vu les comics j'en fais
partie la vie n'est pas tout rose et la
mort en fait partie wolverine n'est pas
éternel et au final et comme monsieur
tout le monde
les héros n'existent pas et tout est
exagéré depuis le début voilà le message
que je peux comprendre du film alors
merci à ceux qui les soins pouces bleus
et qui partageront cette vidéo je n'ai
rien à ajouter de plus que le line
alors soit avec vous c'était dargaud
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]